Milutin was in Hong Kong saying this is
where you had to go to see capitalism in
action now what has happened is perhaps
not that China took over Hong Kong but
more like Hong Kong took over China hi
I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV and
today we're happy to be talking about
Yellen Norberg the Swedish based author
of most recently financial Fiasco and
also the host of the great new
documentary free or equal Yun thanks for
talking to us
thank you free or equal traces or
retraces the route that Milton and Rose
Friedman took in free to choose the path
breaking documentary from decades ago
what did you find as you went around the
world looking at some of the places
where the Friedman's had been years ago
well it's really a mixed record in a way
because during this 30 years the first
thing that has really happened is that
so many places have picked up become
influenced by those ideas and started
implementing them we can go to places
like Estonia where we really had a prime
minister who read the book version of
free to choose or to Chyna Middleton was
in Hong Kong saying this is where you
had to go to to see capitalism in action
now what has happened is perhaps not
that China took over Hong Kong but more
like Hong Kong took over China it's
really a dramatic revolution and I guess
the single biggest global change was the
collapse of communism which had a
massive effect certainly in places like
Estonia and China where are the places
that are lagging behind that are
actually that might be in worse shape
than they were 35 years ago well
obviously we can see that we have that
problem in Africa worldwide we've seen
an incredible poverty reduction almost
everywhere 140,000 people are lifted out
of extreme poverty every day and yet it
continues to grow in some place where
they don't have the basic institutions
of rule of law and trade and so on but
also some parts of the former communist
Empire we can see a backlash in Russia
where we've seen not free market
capitalism rather some sort of state
directed state to crony capitalism
instead what about in the OECD countries
or the developed world you know
interestingly over the past 20 years or
so we've had the Japanese lost decade we
seem to be well into an American
decade throughout the 90s a lot of
European countries Western European
countries cut government spending as a
percentage of the economy but now that
we've been in a number of years of
financial crisis are kind of like less a
fair or free markets on the march or are
they in retreat in the places that once
benefited yeah it is some mixed wrecked
good because the basic story I think is
a great success a revolution in personal
freedom and free markets around the
world and yet what is really stunning
when you look at the free original free
to choose documentaries and the kind of
ideas that the Friedman's visited you
can see that so many of those battles
have to be fought again and again and
specifically after the financial crisis
you can see all those things with
bailouts of private companies government
takeover of industries health care and
so on as stimulus packages massive debt
and so on and that's what makes you a
little bit depressed when you see this
because they could see things so clearly
and how this would would ruin things and
somehow we thought we'd won those debate
but they they always come back
a big part of kind of Friedman's thought
and in free to choose is the idea that
economic freedom leads to political
freedom did you see things that kind of
bear that out
or does that thesis get complicated or
did you find that it's really just not
operative I think that history has shown
that there's a lot to that idea
definitely we've seen that in Latin
America we've seen that in East Asia as
people grow richer as they become more
used to personal freedoms of different
sorts they also demand a stake in a
political sphere as well but who also
see exceptions that china is the big
exception singapore is another exception
where it's still been it possible for a
small tiny elite to sort of give people
the material goods and in exchange
people keep quiet but at the same time
it's too soon to tell because you can
really see that something dramatics
taking place beneath that surface in the
United States and you write a lot about
Europe and about the United States the
book about the financial crisis in the
US and the roots of it Europe in in the
US press we talk a lot about the austere
measures that are being imposed in
Europe whereas the US seems to be going
on a major cain't Keynesian bender our
austerity measures actually taking place
in Europe and if so are they helping or
are they hurting the kind of restart of
the economy yeah
austerity measures are taking place and
that's not really because that debate
has been won by those who love austerity
it's because we're out of money in so
many places so that's the only thing you
can do if the markets don't dare to lend
you more money you have to do something
about it and it's really quite dramatic
and it's quite radical as some places
took the lead and some places that were
more influenced by the Friedman's like
Estonia and Latvia they had a GDP drop
of 15-20 percent and radical austerity
and that austerity in the short run it
also led to less consumption and
probably reinforces this drop in GDP on
the other hand they're back much quicker
they can see a new growth rates this
year and they and now private jobs are
coming back so it seems like there's
something when the government keeps
spending it also crowds out all the
private investments and you know that if
the government builds up all these debts
sooner or later you are going to have to
pay for this so then you become a bit
concerned you don't want to hire you
don't want to consume so it seems like a
start it can be a way forward as well
well I want to thank you on norburg the
host of the great new documentary free
or equal which is going to be available
on PBS throughout America and it'll be
showing up in all sorts of places Yoann
thanks for joining us thank you